let me ask you this
uh why do you think it is
that
testosterone levels are are are dropping
so
significantly in the male population
yeah it's then it's true right first of
all that's like that's been documented
this might be a good time to mention by
the way that there was a study that came
out in a good journal about
reproductive health and hormones that
showed that followed some men after they
underwent coven 19 vaccination with one
of the mrna vaccines
and that was followed by a decrease in
in sperm count and in sperm motility
and it is a temporary
it didn't so that was really nice
wording if you looked at the table and
this is this is uh again this is like my
space right in the space of a lot of my
colleagues that i work with
so if you pull up that study that was
published a few months ago and you look
at the table
doesn't look
fully temporary so the the levels that i
can't remember whether it was 12 weeks
afterward the measures are still lower
than baseline and at least one of the
cells in the in the uh one of the areas
in the table was substantially lower
than baseline so anyway i digress i will
i will just i'll state just because we
we segment
the
we create segments so previous
statements won't be heard in this one uh
we've got to be careful about single
studies
when one study comes out and shows
something you need way more than that
before you can draw heavy conclusions as
to what they mean correct well
you do need to be careful
in this particular study it was done
it seemed like it was done well there
was another study that was done earlier
in the pan am pandemic that didn't find
a difference that there they concluded
that there wasn't a difference in sperm
function or sperm count
so that that's true
ultimately the truth is one you know one
of those studies is is accurate
i think from what i've seen it was it's
i there probably is a decrement in the
in the in the activity in the in the
counts of the sperms coming back to your
point
and in terms of um in terms of
these testosterone so that fits the
pattern of something that isn't
environmental some environmental
exposure and we have a lot of them so
you know why is it i don't know but it
does fit the pattern of you know a sort
of non-natural phenomenon but you know
could it be
social
so uh men aren't chopping lumber anymore
i mean physical exercise increases
testosterone right
it i do believe it does but more in
older men really not sure about i'm not
sure if it increases testosterone if
it's related to testosterone levels in
younger men i i'm not sure what about
hunching over staring at a computer
screen drinking pepsi for 12 hours you
joke around but guys asking for no help
i mean that's a legitimate question
right i mean you know to give one
example i don't know if this is correct
but
if this is true but if some some um you
know i've read for example that the
increase in people with nearsightedness
is related to you know the fact that we
are looking at screens more and kind of
doing close stuff instead of looking
things farther away or hunting or
whatever
so no i i don't i mean it's funny but
something real is happening those
testosterone levels are substantially
lower than they were in the past have
you have you seen the infamous try guys
video
which infamous one i don't know which
where they get their testosterone yeah
they get their testosterone levels
checked and they have the test out
they're like how old are they their 20s
i think they're all late 20s maybe early
30s at the time
and their testosterone levels were equal
to 80 year old men
yeah i don't
i'm i yeah
okay you know from the top looking down
if someone's in the computer all day
that's kind of like them telling biology
you're not going to need my sperm i am a
machine i'm an electronic organism i'm
going to implant my brain in a machine
when i'm 30 doesn't matter you don't
need me anyway my so the body's just
like i mean obviously this guy's not
interacting with women he doesn't need
to be producing testosterone he's
getting what are you telling us
something hey i love my girlfriend
alright
she plays video games too
uh but yeah i am telling you something
when i started doing youtube and making
videos i threw world of warcraft away i
broke the cd and tossed it in the gutter
because i had a massive video game
addiction and for two years i didn't
touch them and i created the most
amazing career uh and created some of
the best friendships of my life to this
day
uh video games
on video games off video it was all off
youtube became my video game uh
interacting with people became my video
game so
there's no understanding of why
testosterone levels are dropping really
i wish i had studied it better prepared
for your quiz today yeah no i just it's
not an area i've studied i wish i had
and it isn't important what do you think
like dudes are going to become shorter
weaker less muscle mass less bone
density i think it's probably not a good
thing that testosterone levels are you
know are falling i see i see this i see
this meme all the time that says the y
chromosome is disappearing have you
heard that i haven't heard that
so i think it miss uh it's feminist
misunderstanding what the science
actually is obviously but it's that
males so i was reading about it
males evolve faster than females in
humans at least
and or or should i i should say this is
a
related to the greater male variability
hypothesis are you familiar with that
one i'm no i'm not i'm not this this one
is uh greater male male variability
hypothesis states that
among men there will be a greater
variation in physical traits
uh as opposed to women and that's
because
you know men this the best the strongest
the most successful will reproduce with
the women right
and so if you have a wide if you have
zero iq to uh to a thousand iq
that wide range allows the best of the
best to have stronger and better
children and to try and fight you know
fight for the women and then women can
choose whichever man is is better or the
you know depending on what year it is if
it's the caveman era it's not not so
pretty for the women
but so
uh in that
the the idea basically is i forgot where
i was what i was starting on now that
we're talking about greater amount of
the y chromosomes disappearing right
right the idea is that
among the greater variability of males
the y chromosome changes substantially
so you know to create
a higher chance of mutations and
alterations in the human body and then
the failure mutations cease to exist die
off don't have kids the successful
mutations end up having kids feminists
have taken this to say oh because the y
chromosome is smaller now than it was
before or whatever that means men will
eventually disappear instead of
well the reality is it could get bigger
and larger and just come back and force
who knows
i'll miss you guys when you all
disappear i have really enjoyed the
video we're alive now
so we're not just gonna die and you're
not gonna be immortal or maybe i don't
know maybe that sounds like awful there
are no like it's just a bunch of women
we're in the oceans movie all over again
i live in new york and it's basically
that already isn't it pass not forget
you know i'll tell you that i i haven't
heard of
i'm not familiar with that sort of
theory
i'll tell you what kind of along the
same lines is concerning
are individuals who believe that
the differences between boys and girls
don't have a natural
root
that
i've read these people's writings and
and they're just completely they're
disconnected from reality because boys
and girls are different
oh don't get me started man you know i
read this study once that said
at birth like within 24 hours female
infants and male infants react to things
differently like female infants are uh
much more interested in faces and male
infants are much more likely to be
looking at like what's beeping
from the beginning show differences
like mechanical options right right i
just watched a video on instagram i
think about a seven-year-old doing a 900
on a skateboard maybe it was nine i
don't know either way he was in the
single digits of age
a nine-year-old boy a seven-year-old boy
just this tiny little kid tiny the board
was as tall as he was
and it was one of the
just most amazing so for those
unfamiliar with skateboarding 900 it's
like a legit seriously difficult
maneuver
uh it was first done in 1999 by tony
hawk it was considered a huge moment in
the history of skateboarding and then
the fir the second one was landed you
know like 10 years later i think it was
something like that maybe it was like
eight years later or something but then
the first 1080 which is three complete
rotations was done by a 12 year old boy
12 year old boy so tony hawk was like 30
when he landed the first 900 which is
two and a half spins
followed by a 12 year old boy to the
first full three rotations adding an
extra half spin to it
now you've got little kids in the single
digits landing this once
insane move
no girls
no gross that proves it
but but i mean it's it's it's anecdotal
but maybe it's a little bit more than
that if you're doing an observational
study and you take a look at all of the
10 year old boys and girls who have been
skating the same amount of time and you
wonder why it is that even before
puberty
boys are landing historical feats in
skateboarding and the girls don't come
close and when i say don't come close i
mean with with all due respect
when when you know when you watch tennis
i couldn't tell you the difference if i
see two guys playing tennis
i see him hitting the ball i see to him
play tennis i see him hitting the ball
don't know because i can't see it
you show anyone skateboarding and you
show them a 12 year old boy jumping a 70
foot gap then going up a 25 foot tall
wall a half pipe quarter pipe and
landing a 1080 45 feet up in the air and
you're going wow
and then you watch the girls skate it
and they don't do it at all because it's
too advanced and they're the same age
with the same same year's skateboarding
there's there's clearly something there
so i researched it the first thing
that's really obvious is fast switch
muscles from prenatal as a result of
prenatal testosterone which is is my
understanding a huge factor in muscle
development so even before puberty
this this idea that if you give these
these sex changes to these children or
hormonal therapies
before they hit puberty they can become
the other
you know at least to a to a greater
degree passing or whatever they want to
call it
that's that's all in the eye beholder i
suppose the issue is
even before puberty from birth there are
distinct physical differences that are
very obvious and discernible between
males and females
yeah i think that's true i mean you
would know better than i i
always think about um
this
tweet that i saw and it was a dad being
like there was a there was a time and it
probably still true but when it was
really big to be like you gotta you
gotta give your kids not like a mixed
array of gender toys so if you have a
daughter buy her barbies but also buy
her tonka trunks and if you have a son
get him a play kitchen as well as like
tools or whatever it is to encourage you
know not being trapped in gender
stereotypes and this dad was like oh i
did it and he takes a picture and it's
his daughter who has tucked her tonka
trucks into bed into like a barbie bed
because for whatever reason like the
trucks are her babies and she's gonna
take care of them and that is really
inherent he's this dad is actively
trying to not reinforce gender
stereotypes and she's doing it anyways i
think physiologically and in the brain
there are clear differences from an
early age and it is confusing for
children to be told well you shouldn't
behave that way because it's sort of bad
in a way that is complicated to explain
to you um i don't know why this also
occurred to me one of the things i think
about the try guy video
when they test their testosterone
i don't know a ton about them but i know
that the only the guy who's scored the
highest on the test not that it's like a
winning but sort of winning uh is the
only one who's married and he might
still be i'm not sure but like at the
time he was the only married guy so so
the question
marriage correlation was was getting
married
what caused his testosterone to go up or
is it because he had high testosterone
he got this or are our marriage rates
falling because our testosterone rates
are falling i think that's probably very
likely and i i attribute personally a
lot to diet when i eat crappy i do not
feel sexy at all and normally i feel
sexy let me just get that on the table i
don't know though you look at people
like uh tiger woods wasn't he he was
like called promiscuous whatever south
park did the whole thing on it mm-hmm
that was really really funny i don't
know if you guys ever saw the south park
episode where they were like we don't
understand why it is that rich
successful men are sleeping with so many
women like what's what's going what's up
with that they could they were confused
by it
so i actually wonder if
i don't know if the marriage thing
correlates to a certain degree right low
t guys are probably not successful in
their relationships but i would i would
argue that the high tea guys
the you know like what we're seeing with
the um
it was the okcupid data that women
overwhelmingly choose the top 20 of men
so like the higher tea guys are getting
all the women yeah you know well and
like not getting married either high
testosterone correlates to the way you
present right like i don't know if this
is true but someone told me once that
uh men going bald is actually a sign of
high testosterone in men and so like
there are things that socially we
wouldn't necessarily
think of that we are subtly picking up
on the way people present or you know
you probably can do this but i don't
like quoting medical advice in front of
the doctor the the speaking from
experience the the baldness thing is
sensitivity to i think dht what's dht
you know that better than me was it diet
remember i mean hydrogen testosterone is
that it is um because you know look i
got to be honest
me and brian stout there are very
different people neither of us have hair
so you know it's like the warrior in you
like your hair's already gone so no one
can grab it if you find yourself in
combat maybe
i don't know
well you know um
i don't know i i wear my hair short but
what i will contribute to this
conversation is that we've got three
boys and we do exactly that because you
know whatever like we just let them
play with what they want right so what
these some of these people believe is
that well it's all a construct boys only
like you know they like the toy cars
because that's all you give them and
girls like the dolls because that's all
you give them and obviously they're
exceptions to everything but that's
that's that is literally factually
incorrect you know yes i think it's i
think the right thing to do is to let
your kids play what they want because
guess what that's who they are and you
you can fight it as long as you want but
that will never change and so you ought
not fight it and you should go with
whatever they are you know there's
something interesting to be said about
um
not knowing things exist they can't ask
for it right right right no yeah exactly
so
what we do is we let them play with what
they want it just so it turns out that
you know one of our boys likes this type
of toy the other way and they all you
know they all like kind of boys stuff
but um you know so anyway i agree with
letting them play with whatever they
want yeah i think it's funny that
they're like you know girls play with
dolls and boys play with action figures
like bro they're dolls
joints
i had barbies growing up for a little
while and all of my brothers gi joes
would occasionally come by and either
murder my garbage or marry them it was
really hard to tell what would happen i
want to encourage people not to well one
of the things i'm concerned with is that
people will overcompensate with this
conversation of testosterone and go for
the high tea because i think a balanced
tea you see i think john mcafee i don't
want to put the guy on blast john if
you're still out there i love you man
what do you mean if he's still out there
he's still alive
he uploaded himself i think he was high
tea like was was taking testosterone
supplements you can see his face was
really red skin is very leathery like
too much yeah no it can increase the
risk of um of blood clots for example i
mean i i don't recommend that what i do
recommend is that people eat as clean as
possible in terms of avoiding the you
know pesticides eating as organic as
possible
which like used to be how all food was
but now you actually have to go seek it
out and exercising right you know some
some resistance training too
i mean you know that's probably as good
as you can do
overall these days
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you